私は中心はコロンビアでコロンビアで馬を買いました
持ってたんですか?自分の馬ですか?
自分の馬です
それで今まで両方買いました
乗ってられたかな?
乗っているのは週末朝の夜まで山をすっと一緒に
まさに馬はあなたを連れて行く
夜になったら早く帰りたいと
そうじゃない?
試合の時もそうです
試合に出ても帰りたくても帰りたい
モンゴルとかもありますよね
一日草原を走って行けるに止まって
またずっと走って夜に行けるに止まって
永遠にモンゴルの草原を走るツアーとかあります
はいはいはいはいはい
うん
ロングスと一緒にやるスポートは
お前に行けるの?
うんうんうん
そうです
感じるの
あ
とてもお前に
ここに
残りたい
座りながら
はいはいはい
お友達も
いいんですよ
お友達も来て
ここでずーっと
夕方まで
夕方
知らったように
あとはずっと
ここで
ラッテルスといっぱいいます
とてもいい心地
ね
なあかんきゃあ
ロングシェア
ラッテルスといっぱい
やっていまして
素晴らしい
うわぁすごいですよね
うん
すごい乗られる
伸るんですよ
これとかあの
フランスで私の
これはフランスのね
サロン・ドーツーミーって
そういうところに
出しました
去年
すごい
10月に
展示会はいつもあって
今年も1枚出してます
うまく
はい
お札と
お札とお札になって
時間はそうなんです
はい
その頃はあまり乗ってなくて
結構厳しい学校の出張になって
そうですね
はい